foreign
people are not born great they become
great
[Music]
we are born with a cry we die with the
groan All That Remains is to live with
laughter
[Music]
fate never opens one door without first
closing another
[Music]
life is the flower for which love is the
honey
[Music]
the Supreme happiness in life is the
Assurance of being loved
[Music]
even the darkest night will end and the
sun will rise
[Music]
the soul helps the body and at certain
moments raises it it is the only bird
that sustains its cage
[Music]
there is nothing more powerful than an
idea whose time has come
[Music]
laughter is sunshine it chases winter
from the human face
[Music]
nothing makes a man so adventurous as an
empty pocket
[Music]
I would rather be the head of a fly than
the tale of a lion
[Music]
music expresses that which cannot be put
into words and that which cannot remain
silent
[Music]
change your opinions keep your
principles change your leaves keep
intact your roots
[Music]
music can change the world because it
can change people
[Music]
there is always more misery among the
lower classes than there is Humanity
among the higher
he who opens a school door closes a
prison
many great actions are committed in
small struggles
[Music]
mother's arms are made of tenderness and
children sleep soundly in them
[Music]
when a woman is talking to you listen to
what she says with her eyes
[Music]
be like the bird who pausing in her
flight a while on bows too slight feels
them give way beneath her and yet sings
knowing she has wings
short as life is we make it still
shorter by the careless waste of time
[Music]
there is nothing like a dream to create
a future
[Music]
the most powerful symptom of Love is a
tenderness which becomes at times almost
insupportable
Joy is the reflex of Terror
[Music]
the wicked envy and hate it is their way
of admiring
[Music]
our mind is enriched by what we receive
our heart by what we give
[Music]
to love another person is to see the
face of God
thank you
to learn to read is to light a fire
every syllable that is spelled out is a
spark
Fame must have enemies as light must
have gnats
[Music]
strong and bitter words indicate a weak
cause
[Music]
each man should frame life so that at
some future hour facts and dreams meet
[Music]
to love beauty is to see light
if you can imagine anything scarier than
a hell of suffering it is a hell of
boredom
[Music]
what would be ugly in a garden is
beautiful on a mountain
[Music]
taste is a common sense of Genius
pain is as diverse as man one suffers as
one can
[Music]
our acts make or maras we are the
children of our own Deeds
[Music]
one can resist the invasion of an army
but one cannot resist the invasion of an
idea
[Music]
faith is a necessity to man woe to him
who believes in nothing
[Music]
by putting forward the hands of the
clock you shall not Advance the hour
once these qualities at a distance and
defects at close range
[Music]
one good thing about music when it hits
you you feel no pain
[Music]
there are two Infinities the universe
and human stupidity
[Music]
no one watches the actions of others as
jealously as those who are least
affected by them
the paradise of the rich is created out
of the hell of the poor
[Music]
books are friends impassioned but loyal
some thoughts are prayers there are
times when the soul regardless of the
position of the body is on its knees
to travel means to be born and to die
every second
when a person is possessed by a thought
he finds it in everything
the doors of a coffin do not open from
the inside
if a man can tell what love is then he
hasn't loved anyone
[Music]
the strongest power is an innocent heart
fear not it is the only way to progress
[Music]
eyes cannot see God well except through
tears
hell is contained in one word loneliness
[Music]
when an innocent man is punished an
ungodly one is born
When Love is Happy it leads the soul to
sweetness and goodness
[Music]
there are no small countries the
greatness of a nation is not measured by
the number of its members just as the
greatness of a man is not measured by
his height
[Music]
once you cure a hawk spattered Wing you
become responsible for its claws
in first love the soul is taken before
the body later it is taken before the
soul and sometimes no soul is taken at
all
[Music]
to be useful is only to be useful to be
beautiful is only to be beautiful
but to be useful and beautiful is to be
great
[Music]
winter turns the water falling from the
sky and people's hearts to Stone
[Music]
before a great mind I bow my head before
a great heart I kneel
[Music]
caution is the oldest child of wisdom
God created the cat so that man could
have a tiger to pet
idleness is the happiness of children
and The Misfortune of old people
[Music]
don't teach your children to be rich
teach them to be happy so they know the
value of things not the price
[Music]
who does not control his own thoughts
does not control his own actions
[Music]
vanity is a terrible Force working
within us and against ourselves
[Music]
the conscience of a loving man is the
guardian angel of the woman he loves
[Music]
a man is strong in mind a woman is
strong in weakness
a man without a woman is like a gun
without a trigger
[Music]
love is when people don't join souls or
bodies it's when they join destinies
[Music]
a house without books is like a body
without a soul
[Music]
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments